you know please be seated and hello
class of 2017 my name is Kai Gill and
this is Janice Lee and as co-chairs of
your graduation committee we are
delighted to have you all here today to
celebrate with us a huge milestone in
our lives
we are gathered here today to celebrate
finally completing our education with
yet another commencement ceremony for
the past four years we've learned a lot
first we learned the power being
involved also known as joining student
organizations to pillows their outline
bangs we've learned the importance of
legal research that footnotes add a full
two pages to any final paper we learned
about punctuality that is if a box
launch starts at 12:10 you show up at
11:55 jokes aside we've learned to
become a part of the legal and Columbia
Law School community and it is a
responsibility that we'll carry with us
for the rest of our lives today we
commemorate becoming a part of the
Alumni community and in doing so we owe
a debt of gratitude the faculty
administrators our fellow students and
most importantly the family and friends
who are here today continuing to support
us as we complete this journey you've
taken our frantic 2 a.m. phone calls
during finals you've listened to our
rambles about EIP the Blue Book without
even knowing what either of those things
are and you've helped us believe in
ourselves and our dreams beyond just
your support we thank you for showing up
to celebrate with us and we especially
thank Mary Jo white a distinguished and
trailblazing alumni for her example and
her remarks this morning finally
finally thank you to the class of 2017
you've taught me the importance of
supporting one another from my closest
friends to the person who unknowingly
let me use their empty Locker all year
you inspire me to work harder and to be
better I now like to welcome Jillian
lesser Dean and Lucy Gigi Moses
professor of law to the podium Thank You
Kai and Janice distinguished guests
family and friends faculty and
administrators and graduates it's my
great pleasure to welcome you here today
to mark the graduation of Columbia Law
School's class of 2017
[Applause]
graduates today we celebrate a milestone
you've been working towards since you
began your time here at Columbia Law
School and you've worked hard there have
been long days and late nights but the
day has arrived and you have earned all
the pomp circumstance and celebration
that goes along with it
congratulations but as I'm sure you know
this accomplishment is a shared one I'm
looking out at the roughly 5,000 parents
children family members friends and
loved ones who flanked this stage these
are the people to whom you've turned for
support for encouragement for guidance
they are here today as they have been
with you throughout this journey all of
us owe them recognition and gratitude
thank you
and graduates this is a day on which
even if you look to the future you may
be already feeling nostalgia for what
you will leave behind you are not alone
in feeling nostalgic celebrating with
you here today are members of the class
of 1967 who this year marked the 50th
anniversary of their graduation from
Columbia Law School class of 1967 we we
thank you for your 50 years of
distinguished contributions to society
and for your loyalty to Columbia Law
School please rise so we make if our
hats to you
[Applause]
graduation address is often focused on
the theme of change after all graduation
is a time of closure transition and new
beginnings change is inevitable and the
future is full of possibility
what more apt message than an
exhortation to seize the day embrace the
new and find opportunity in what lies
ahead well I believe in all those things
I believe in being brave and in taking
risks I believe in the power of
reinvention I believe in a full and
spirited embrace of new experiences in
fact I once delivered a speech that said
all of those things on September 11th
2014 I gave my first speech to a class
at Columbia Law School that class was
the JD class that sits before me the
occasion your 1l dinner but today I
don't want to talk about things that
will change or the changes that you
yourselves will shape in the years ahead
No instead I want to try to I want to
talk about the things you should try not
to change the things you must preserve
for example when you came to Columbia
you also made the decision to open
yourself to the acquisition of new
knowledge throughout your time in law
school your core mission has been clear
to learn while pursuing that mission
you've become expert in a new way of
thinking one that insists fundamentally
on analytic rigor perhaps to the chagrin
of your family members who like to enjoy
a nice quiet holiday meal your teachers
as well as your peers have given you a
more textured and nuanced view of the
world and you use the opportunity
to learn from and alongside others with
different experiences to develop
confidence and to grow as a person but
here is what you need to preserve the
curiosity and the humility that have
enabled you to open your minds in this
way as your personal and professional
lives flourish don't assume you're done
with this period in your life your
education in many ways has only just
begun here's another thing that mustn't
change most of you came to law school in
pursuit of some goals or ideal you
believed that legal training would help
you do or fix something maybe you wanted
to bring justice to a community you care
about or become a great litigator or
work across borders or fix the tax code
or reenact the final arguments from my
cousin Vinnie well now you have the
tools to do whatever it was that brought
you here in the first place the problem
is that law school made you wiser about
how hard it may be to accomplish that
vision so maybe you need to adjust yes
perhaps it's more complicated than you
would thought but that doesn't mean you
should abandon the idealism or the
inspiration that drove you to study law
embrace it
take it on realize the promise of the
tools we have given you and rise to meet
the challenge
that's what Colombians do best
a third change you must guard against
with the degrees you earn today you
become stewards of our most vital
institutions you have a responsibility
to protect the rule of law and the core
values substantiated in our
constitutional order Rights and Freedoms
that protect equality and expression due
process of law and the rules of ethics
and accountability that preserve trust
and stability in society this will not
always be easy the world is a tumultuous
and unpredictable place and the very
foundations of our democratic
institutions will sometimes be shaken
but these are precisely the times when
society will turn to you most urgently
this is not an argument against change
in the law it is an argument about the
preservation of the integrity of the law
even as law evolves to meet the
standards of a changing society you must
safeguard its legitimacy and the
fairness of its application finally
finally cherish and preserve the
relationships you've formed here at
Columbia Law School in the time you've
been here you've made friends among
classmates professors and staff members
they have stood beside you cheering you
on and supporting you at every juncture
don't let the passage of time sever
these bonds these friendships the ones
you form in law school these will be the
friendships that sustain you for the
rest of your life in fact some of you
may know this years researching prize
honoree is someone that I met in law
school 24 years and two children later I
couldn't be more proud to share the
stage with him today
now I know I said that I didn't want to
talk about things that will change but
let me leave you with this preserving
these essential elements of your time at
Columbia Law School your commitment to
learning your guiding vision your
professional obligations and your solid
friendships these are the things that
will anchor you as you navigate the
changes that lie ahead class of 2017 on
behalf of all of us here at Columbia Law
School I salute you and I bit wish you
the best of all things in the years to
come
[Applause]
class of 2017 congratulations
we made it thank you to our parents
family and friends without your love and
support we would not be walking across
this stage today to our faculty staff
and administrators thank you for
teaching us to be better advocates and
citizens I'm honored to be speaking here
today but I have to be honest I didn't
know what to say in the speech I mean I
could talk about myself how I got here
how Columbia changed me but nobody came
to this graduation to hear about me not
even my family believe it or not even
they are sick of hearing me talk about
myself
it gets tiring at 25 years I don't blame
them with that off the table my second
instinct was to give advice but then I
wondered what if I leave these people
astray I mean I don't even follow my own
advice and that actually has steered me
pretty well so rather than do any of
that or leave you with some lofty
message you've heard before I thought
I'd take this opportunity to talk about
you the class of 2017 you have all
amazed challenged and inspired me and
while it's impossible to talk about all
of you in a three-minute speech I wanted
to take this time to highlight a few of
the amazing things you have done so here
we go Alice Steven you have been a
relentless champion for first-generation
professionals and countless students
have found the resources and confidence
they need to succeed because of your
work
the head has Eve and Zeynep Qureshi at a
time at a time when religious difference
has bred division and intolerance you
brought our community together through
the faith and practice panel your work
has made Colombia a more welcoming
community for people of all religions
increase Rebecca our keola and Hannah
white bro you inspired us all
by winning asylum for refugee as law
students or en Hakala and winning food
network cooked vs. cons you proved
Columbia law students can walk and talk
at the same time Rasheed Ahmed you
showed your courage had no bomb when you
asked for a shout-out in the speech
[Music]
Zeid Yadira remoter bert you
accomplished perhaps the most ardent
challenge you somehow survived the
impossible odds of Dean or no Dean we're
better as a community and as a law
school because of your work you may not
be a student but you are one of us
the list of course goes on one of the
greatest benefits of this place and one
of the reasons we all came here was to
be surrounded by so much success
dedication and passion but the greatest
privilege has been to count on one
another
after all our accomplishments have been
contingent on having each other's
support the strength in our class lies
in our friendship and it has since the
very beginning I mean let's be honest
the best part of one our year was
looking to our last and right in legal
methods and seeing the promise of
friendship the best part of to all was
recognizing that we didn't have to do it
all alone that we could look to others
for support and in the process gain a
friend the best part of 3l was looking
across the table while cramming a
semesters worth of learning into one
night and realizing all our friends were
right there with us doing the same and
that is the beauty of this place knowing
that whether a transfer LLM our court
Bob Strauss Ginsburg or even a Ruth
Bader Ginsburg we will all walk out of
this place better people because the
friends we have made here thank you and
congratulations again the Columbia Law
School Class of
it is my honor it is my honor to
introduce Andres Barajas the JD class
speaker has it been elected by popular
vote of our class
[Applause]
good morning everyone I'm in the US and
I wrote a speech this is it we've
already started it's a thank-you speech
okay
JD's in 2014 we started strong as one
else well I mean we weren't strong at
all we're very weak actually we worried
and stressed about everything do you
remember how during 1l year we used to
be so afraid of bombing a cold call yeah
as three elves we realized you can't
bomb a cold call if you don't show up to
class I'm kidding a quick so we've come
a long way and I've been asking myself
how did we get here how did we get here
well the answer I came up with is with
help so first off I want to thank the
incredible people at Columbia Law School
including our facilities workers our
librarians our wonderful staff our
distinguished faculty and our
administrators thank you all
I also want to thank two other groups of
people for helping us get here today
first our families and by family I also
mean our chosen family of friends
mentors significant others all the
people who helped us along the way
families thank you for helping us see
that education is incredibly important I
mean personally you know growing up in
poverty in rural all over California
going to college for me was a reach and
going to law school wasn't even on my
radar right I didn't even know Columbia
Law School existed but I'm here now
because my mom was sitting over here
somewhere
always told my brothers and me that
education was the key to a better life
so thank you mom I love you
families families whatever we
accomplished in life you accomplished
thank you for always believing in us
even when we had crazy ideas like I
think I want to go to law school um I
remember first saying that to a friend
five years ago the first law student I'd
ever known so when she told me I'm the
best you would love law school you can
totally do this I was encouraged if you
were lucky enough to have someone in
your life root for you like that be sure
to thank them thank you families the
second group of people I think we should
all be think before is each other our
classmates classmates you have been the
best part of law school and then thank
you for every time that you told me I
don't understand that either that really
helped it helps so much thank you for
putting all the work you put into
student organizations and and journals
thank you for feeding and educating us
at the same time with your amazing lunch
talks and symposiums you put on
essentially classmates what I'm saying
is thank you all for caring
we are clearly going through a very
challenging time in our country and our
world right now but that's all I'm going
to say about that because when I look
around this morning and I see this many
good people who are about to become
lawyers with real power I like our
chances so thank you classmate more
thing
finally class of 2017 I just wanna say
that we are so privileged to have had
the chance to study here at Columbia Law
School we are so in with a quote that I
feel best captures this feeling listen
for me I can't worry about what
everybody say about me I'm LeBron James
from Akron Ohio
from the inner city I'm not even
supposed to be here that's enough every
every night I walk into the locker room
I see a number six with James on the
back I'm blessed
class of 2017 LeBron is right we are
blessed I hope you feel that way today
and every day going forward I'm a huge
fan of y'all congratulations
I now pleased to introduce Gonzalo go
the third who will speak for the master
of law class of 2017 having been elected
by popular vote of that class okay I
better bring the microphone down
distinguished guests members of the
faculty proud parents family friends and
fellow graduates the Columbia Law School
LLM class of 2017 is made up of 313
remarkable women as men with diverse
backgrounds from around the world we
came here to become better versions of
ourselves to learn from global legal
experts and to explore New York City our
band our Bunch has been very unique
right from the start we gave ourselves a
head start by eagerly meeting as a class
three days before the official
orientation started to share stories
meet new friends and learn to pronounce
each other's names the class selfie we
took at the end of that night was for
telling of the wonderful year ahead of
us armed with our official CLS t-shirts
backpacks and mobile app we took in a
barrage of information during
orientation we located big Warren little
Warren and quickly learned which you are
in offers free cookies and coffee
[Applause]
we were side by side as we all absorb an
array of acronyms GLS is soo PTI al la
wo TSS ji n PR UV and the notorious RBG
[Applause]
which would be central to our life
during the humming month
then came the add/drop period when we
found ourselves listed and wait-listed
in classes taught by renowned professors
we had only read about before coming
over while balancing our challenging
course loads we still managed to find
time to explore the city go museum
hopping do pro bono work mingle and make
new friends
be amused and concerned about
alternative facts and grab some extra
sleep during the last few weeks before
the final exams throughout throughout
all these milestones the office of
Graduate Legal Studies always helped
lead us to reason
Thank You Dean polo Jill Marisa Megan
and Jennifer for constantly being
available to answer our questions and
address our apprehensions and today
after having successfully obtained our
having successfully submitted our LLM
papers and satisfy the rigorous
requirements of our professors in this
prestigious school we are ready to
receive our diplomas and make history
[Applause]
thank you to to our parents partners
sponsors siblings children professors
administrators and stuff you made this
experience possible and hands down
amazing my overflowing gratitude goes to
my parents
Winston and Marilyn your sacrifices but
meaning in everything I have and as
always you are my moral compass as I
consider the opportunities ahead we are
one of the community but we try this
year because we are individually driven
each one of us has our own stories to
tell of our home of our struggles of our
different nations we all came here for
different reasons with different views
and different agendas but therein lies
the beauty of our Columbia Law School
experience and in our individual
friendships helped us broaden our mind
and in doing so we never lost ourselves
Columbia Law School provided us with
safe spaces to unmask our fears to
discuss and neutralize our biases and
prejudices and to be sensitive to what
it is like to be on the opposite side of
the fence on any given issue without
losing our own convictions and
principles we now pack our bags and go
our separate ways we take with us not
only the profound learnings of this year
but also a renewed sense of intellectual
hunger and passion for truth we will
champion transparency justice diversity
and inclusiveness equipped with the
privilege
thank equipped with a privilege of a
Columbia degree we now serve as potent
instruments to improve our communities
by enhancing human rights and common
decency we take on the task of
dispelling oppressive distinctions based
on nationality color ethnicity gender
creed disability and social economic
background let us stand proud and build
a global community where everyone is
from welcome value supported and
celebrated together with my fellow LLM
class mates with bid goodbye for now to
Morningside Heights and to one another
let us remain connected forever a
community of colleagues and friends with
the support of family and friends
respect of peers and admiration of the
people we lead always be enough to
propel us to the highest peaks leaving
no one behind congratulations class of
2017 and as we traditionally say in the
Philippines
Mabuhay pata Omaha
[Applause]
Chiqui preview of what's to come
good morning my name is Beatrice Kelly
and I am delighted today to be
presenting the Willis L M Reese prize
for excellence in teaching professor
Eric Talley
I have to confess that when I signed up
for Professor Tally's fall 2015
corporations class I had unclean hands I
had the singular motive of getting intel
on the new Dean's husband for the Law
Review Show looking back though it seems
incredible that it was ever difficult to
persuade friends to sign up for the
unknown professor section within a week
of the semester beginning
professor Talley had more than
established himself as a faculty member
that students needed to take a class
with sure there were free t-shirts that
said I heart corporations which by the
way will get you a few strange looks
when running in Riverside Park and he
hosted office hours on his bicycle which
meant that you could ask questions for
as long as you could keep up with him
but there was also a clear passion for
teaching students the practical side of
transactional law for instance to teach
us about insider trading
professor Talley provided insight
information to a select group of class
members meaning that some students
inexplicably a stay in class exercise
well this had the immediate effect of
creating an atmosphere of panic in the
classroom
it also definitely taught us why
regulators like our keynote speaker are
concerned about insider trading when I
signed up for Professor Tally's
corporate finance class the next spring
I was floored to find out that the
waitlist was more than twice the
capacity of the class please keep in
mind that this was a class that required
law students to do math at 8:40 in the
morning
not exactly an attractive proposition
particularly for art history majors like
myself professor Tally's M&A class this
semester was initially offered at the
more reasonable hour of 9/10 and when he
moved that one also up to 8:40 a.m. it
was still oversubscribed if anything I
think we should be worried that he'll
try to offer a class at 6 a.m. next year
there is a lot of discussion about
impostor syndrome and how it impacts
students experiences law school the
legal profession generally and the
finance world in particular are
overwhelmingly white and male which
leaves a number of us feeling like we
don't belong but professor Talley leaves
no student behind pushing us to stop
thinking of ourselves merely as
specialists in law and instead as
sophisticated advisors he arms us with
fluency in the language of math and
economics and by forcing us out of our
comfort zone painfully
when happening before 9 a.m. professor
tally allows even students without a
background in finance to enter the world
of corporate law with the confidence
crucial for professional success
professor tally would you please join me
at the podium it is with immense joy
that I present to you the professor
Willis LM Reese prize for excellence in
teaching from the class of 2017
[Applause]
so do you want to graduate what do you
want when do you want it that's good I'm
good all right all right many thanks
class of 2017 and welcome once again
columbia law faculty staff alumni
families and former SEC chairs I use the
plural but maybe just the singular I
can't overstate how honored and humbled
I feel to receive this award it's
particularly gratifying knowing that it
came from you and as you know Columbia
faculty members are expected to balance
research teaching and service activities
and frankly I like all three parts of
this job more or less most of the time
but the one aspect of my job that I love
is the part that happens in the
classroom every day it never gets old it
never gets repetitive and it never gets
easy and that's a theme I'm going to
come back to in a little bit but before
that I want to heap some praise and
props on your classmate meet Miss
Beatrice Kelly for doing me the singular
honor of that introduction now look in
all honesty everyone knows that the
interest is a pretty natural Hamm and
performer so really all she could have
done is disappoint no pressure right
Beatrice but of course she didn't
rendering the job of following her all
the harder now beyond her enviable
skills as a thespian Beatrice embodies
traits that I have grown to admire
greatly in the Columbia law student body
she's smart she's fearless and she is
unbelievably resilient seriously for an
art historian
for an art historian to subject yourself
to present discounted value
black-scholes pricing multivariate
regression and the capital asset pricing
model at 8:40 in the morning is a
telltale sign of either real grit or
possibly dangerous self-destructive
tendencies only time will tell
now students are often told to be on the
lookout for inspiring professors but
here's a little secret the opposite is
true as well we're always on the lookout
for inspiring students in class of 2017
you inspire me so yeah alright let's get
down to business the real upside of the
Reese prize as I see it is neither the
attractive crystal plaque so it is
attractive nor the year supply of
rice-a-roni that accompany it but rather
it's the air time I get to deliver for
what will be for most of you your final
faculty lecture how cool is that yeah
so I'm I'm like licking my chops about
this prospect until Dean Ramos server
dutifully reminded me of the major
ground rules my time would be limited to
eight minutes unless I'm on a roll I
could not use powerpoints no exams or
problem sets no cold calling on any
graduate or any family member of a
graduated oh yeah the lecture has to be
delivered outdoors on a 90 degree day
while wearing a 20-pound velvet and
polyester bathrobe hey but beyond that
no constraints go to a towel you're good
so I start thinking what do you say in a
last lecture how do you encapsulate the
totality of students experiences at CLS
in abbreviated format without seeming
trite or cliched and the fact is I can't
even if I had PowerPoint but what I can
do perhaps is offer a few thoughts for
you to store away somewhere in your
prefrontal cortex as you enter the
coming months years and decades the
final bag of CLS swag if it were so I
want to touch on three themes your life
as a student your tolerance for risk
your professional calling first I want
to talk about your life as a student
many of you no doubt are celebrating the
fact that today marks the triumphant end
to your penurious existence as students
right well about that I have to say that
you are sadly mistaken now this is
starting to sound like a Law School
lecture isn't it
today merely marks the end of your
existence as a tuition paying student
which is no small benefit to be sure
yeah I think the parents can clap at
that one too but your life yeah good
your life as a student continues get
this indefinitely and if it doesn't
you're not doing it right a favorite
quotation of mine comes from a noted
French jazz composer Michel Legrand
who once famously quipped the more I
live the more I learn and the more I
learn the more I realize the less I know
now Iran is still alive and kicking at
85 which makes him about 35 years my
elder so by my reckoning I know a ton
more than he does or at least I think I
do and I guess in turn you must know
more than I but here's one thing that I
think I still know our world's
complicated we make it so on purpose our
social institutions statutes precedents
regulations and norms reflect centuries
long aggregations of our collective
capabilities aspirations and our
limitations and they make for an
environment whose nuanced contours are
ever-changing its force is powerful and
its logical path unclear now in the
coming years you will all by turns
confront facets of this complexity with
your principal remit to make sense that
even a small corner of it and it turns
out that's a big ask
as you grope around remember you're
probably never going to be done doing
that and more important try to
understand the world not only through
the narratives of your allies and your
Facebook connections but also through
those of your adversaries and your
unfriended Facebook connections because
they have a story to tell too and it's
one that we too frequently miss
marginalize or ignore embrace not just
the convenience
but also the inconvenient ones and
insist that others do the same
make no mistake as a lawyer you will owe
a duty to be an effective advocate but
do not confuse that with being
effectively an ideologue they're not the
same thing second I want to talk about
risk even if you're destined to be a
student forever isn't it at least
fantastic that you'll never have to take
another final exam like ever yeah so
about that you're mistaken there once
again even if we don't count the bar
exam indeed you will soon discover that
your prize for winning the metaphorical
pie-eating contest that is law school is
wait for it more metaphorical pie you
are about to begin drafting an answer to
the most intricate issue spotter essay
question ever devised one whose call
asks you to become the author of your
own professional and personal life think
of it as a 50-year take-home exam word
limited of course and I'll even grade it
for you can track me down in the year
2000 67 and I still have my wits about
me
and by the way class 1967 your exams
will be due by 5:00 p.m. today now many
many junctures you also this truly epic
exam answer you're going to confront
seemingly endless sequences of hard
choices where to live and work how to
live and work with whom you spend your
life professional and personal should
you radically change any of the Bob and
because life is sequential it's
naturally going to frame itself each one
of these choices as pitting the status
quo against the unknown the familiar
against the unfamiliar the comfortable
safe play against the discomforting
flyer and it's humans we're
pre-programmed to be risk and
uncertainty averse instinctively
embracing the status quo and reticent
about the unknown and this reticence is
no doubt reinforced by the speed with
which our social media disseminates news
of our every move but I want to caution
you at least within reason to resist
defaulting into the from the
and comfortable while the unfamiliar
path is no doubt fraught with hazards
and unknown unknowns it also has two
wonderful redeeming characteristics the
first which will come as no surprise to
my corporate finance and MA students is
that the most uncertain path also is the
one with the highest option value
allowing you both to learn and to react
as you learn about yourself about your
heretofore undiscovered passions
capabilities opportunities limitations
about your world and this option value
remains high even when it's costly or
impossible to reverse course and the
second factor that redeems the uncertain
path is a little more subtle as I
reflect on my own life thus far I see
scores if not hundreds of mistakes in
fact I cringe recalling some of them as
does I suspect Dean luster sitting
behind me I tend to classify my mistakes
into two camps mistakes of commission
moments where I actively changed course
in a way that I would come to regret and
mistakes of omission moments where I
less actively passed up an opportunity
whose future resolution I would never
see and that's just the thing if my 27
year old self were sitting amongst you
today adorned in one of those stylish
baby blue polyester bathrobes I would
want to impress on him
two things first you must floss
regularly
a root canal at 43 is no way to go I I
kid you not and second when I look back
at my own mistakes in hindsight and I do
they don't add up equally those mistakes
or errors of omission they get ten times
the weight as the errors of commission
the question what might have been is
perhaps the most vexing question that
you can saddle your suit your future
self with so please cut that future self
of yours a break become tolerant of
errors of commission and you might be
surprised as what you get and then
finally I want to talk about your
professional calling believe it or not
this is a terrific time to become a
lawyer for many reasons first after
several years in the doldrums legal
hiring seems to be making a comeback
particularly here in New York which is
great second the world is changing
technologically and with it are so many
facets of our everyday life new practice
areas race to keep up from AI to energy
to personal injury for driverless cars
in third and somewhat paradoxically
we're in a moment of historic and
palpable political and regulatory flux
both nationally and internationally now
the first two reasons I just gave you
make lawyering a sensible occupation but
it's the third that truly makes it a
calling those of you who become members
of the bar and the vast majority of you
will are going to take an oath you will
to paraphrase solemnly swear to support
and defend the state and federal
constitutions and to discharge
faithfully the duties of attorney and
counselor at law according to the best
of your ability
now that oath is going to take less than
45 seconds to recite particularly at the
pace that lawyers typically speak that's
less time than it takes to apply for a
library card two minutes I looked it up
or obtained a driver's license two weeks
it's less in Jersey or even fill out a
tax form but it also carries more
gravity than any of those things and
it's part of what makes lawyer in
different and special today's graduates
of the Columbia Business School they're
not going to be taking oaths
yeah
nor will be engineering students nor the
PhD students in any fields and while the
Medical School graduates will their oath
unlike yours will not require them to
defend public institutions it goes
without saying that you are entering a
workforce in an era of great general
prosperity but also at a moment of
significant political social and legal
unease the combination of international
instability domestic upheaval
socio-economic and racial tension and /
fervid ideological difference is this
pronounced that it has been in my
lifetime but it is in such crises that
lawyers are needed most when they
inevitably step in to become the heroes
and not the punchlines because it's the
lawyers that others look to for
expertise for patience for maturity for
professionalism and as the lawyers who
safeguard constitutional institutions
who fight for individual liberties and
freedoms and who vindicate the rule of
law over the impulses of the feckless
and the powerful and who advocate for
those who cannot advocate for themselves
regardless of class race gender sexual
orientation religion political belief
lineage or national origin so you are it
you are the back-up plan
now a pronouncement like that may send
shivers down your spine along with a
sense of foreboding responsibility that
borders on dread but it doesn't for me
to the contrary I look out on this group
of accomplished and committed graduates
of former and still lifelong students of
smart and fearless and resilient future
leaders and I am filled with confidence
and hope about what lies ahead
for I can think of no group I would
rather see carry forward with the mantle
of this venerable institution this noble
profession and this great country than
the graduates assembled here today
lastly because I have plowed through my
eight minutes I want to say just a few
words about the law school
administration and my family and in the
interest of time I can bundle those two
together this year so I love our Dean
and you know heck we all do but for me
it's poison --all so much so that 19
years ago I finally worked up the nerve
to ask her to marry me and in hindsight
it was one of the luckiest non errors of
commission of my life and and it began a
partnership that sought to embrace the
spirit of the themes I've just discussed
of always learning of tolerating the
litte risks of pursuing one's calling a
pursuit that stared us coldly in the
eyes when a little over two years ago we
decided to uproot our family and move to
New York City and it wasn't easy and I
guess these things never are but hard as
it was it was made many times simpler by
the warmth and infectious enthusiasm
that met her and then me from the
Columbia Law Students when we arrived
many of those same students as it
happens comprise the JD and jst classes
of 2017 and are seated here today and
while the LMS have been here for only a
year are there any LMS out there are
there any yellow lems out there there
you go gotta make some noise if you're
going to be a zealous advocate for the
LMS out there I can't overstate how you
enliven our hallways enrich our
classrooms and enrich our lives on a
daily basis to the Columbia Law School
graduating class of 2017 my most
heartfelt thanks and congratulations to
you as well as your family's partners
and friends I wish you the best of luck
in the great work that lies ahead and I
can't wait to behold both your errors
and your triumphs of commission thank
you
[Applause]
good morning it is still morning
actually I'm all attuned a Johnson I
just want to say congratulations to all
the graduates so I'm here for one reason
every year Columbia Law School honors a
select group of its students to be
recognized for outstanding achievement
and the faculty have selected students
this year to receive awards for their
work in law school clinics for seminar
papers essays notes and work in
specialized fields and the complete list
of these prizes will be on our law
school website tomorrow and announced to
all of you right now it is my pleasure
to announce this year's prize winners in
four categories of broad achievement and
these were selected by the faculty when
I announce your name please stand up I
ask everyone to please hold your
applause until the end so first there's
the Samuel I Rosenman prize this is
awarded to a student who has
demonstrated academic excellence in
public law courses and outstanding
overall leadership in in public service
and public law at the law school and in
the law school community this year the
prize goes to Christopher Hellwig
the Pauline Berman Heller prize is
awarded annually to the graduating
student who has displayed the most
outstanding record of academic
achievement in the service of gender
equality in law business or society and
this is expressed through their
classroom performance their scholarly
research and other activities and this
year the prize goes to Francesca grace
kakuzu next we have the John or Grinnell
prize which is awarded annually to the
JD degree candidate for their general
proficiency and legal scholar that
scholarship and study and this prize
recognizes the student who has the
highest academic average in each JD
graduating class and this year's
recipient is James Weisman
and finally the Walter Gellhorn prize is
awarded annually to an LLM degree
candidate who has whose graduating with
the highest academic average for
outstanding proficiency in legal scholar
and legal study and this prize this year
goes to Benjamin nutburger
so let's give a round of applause for
all the recipients
okay with that I'm now delighted to
introduce Clyde Rankin who's known a
skip class of 1975 to present the
Campbell award on behalf of the Columbia
Alumni Association good morning class of
2017 you look great this morning my name
is skip Rankin member of the class of
1975 and I'm so pleased to be back on
campus today not just as a Columbia alum
but also as a member of the board of
directors of the Columbia Alumni
Association to present the Campbell
Award to a very deserving member of the
class of 2017 but before presenting
today's award I thought I would just
take a few moments to explain to you
some of the reasons behind the creation
of the Campbell award the award was
established in the fall of 2015 by the
board of trustees of Columbia University
and also by the board of directors of
the Columbia Alumni Association its
purpose was to recognize an honor
Colombians who work to build and promote
the spirit of Columbia University as
exemplified by the late Bill Campbell
now many of you didn't have the chance
to know Bill he passed away in 2015 bill
was a member of Columbia College classes
1962 Teachers College 64 former chair of
the board of trustees of Columbia
University football coach of Columbia
College on a mean feat in those days and
he also was co-founder of the Columbia
Lung Association the award was
established in recognitions of bills
service to Columbia and while he is no
longer with us today to present the
award his spirit and the values
associated with his life his humility
his encouragement to others always
working to make things better and
striving to balance between tradition
and innovation these are all values that
are still very much alive and remain
with us today
is particularly rewarding to have such a
deserving graduate the law schools class
of 2007 your own Alex William thinks a
sign as a recipient of the Campbell
Award this year
Alex's most of you know is co-founder
the Columbia law feminist society plus a
staff member on the journal of gender in
law a peer facilitator for the sexual
respect initiative and what she worked
with last year's recipient of the
Campbell Award Catherine de Jiang Alex
also serves a university-wide
gender-based misconduct prevention task
force and he spent this past spring
break working to assist migrant woman
and children detained by ice in their
claims for asylum and helped to secure
their release from detention
well done Alex
alex has demonstrated the unique ability
to help others and to work among various
members of the university community and
to bring people the various backgrounds
to work together I had the pleasure
reviewing the various applications that
were submitted to the CCAA this year for
selection of the recipients Alex who was
an easy choice to select you as the
awardee from the law school you
exemplify all the values and qualities
of Lakeville Campbell I know he would be
pleased today to know that you were
receiving an award in his name
congratulations Alex on all your
achievements and thank you for all that
you do and that you will continue to do
for Columbia Law School and Columbia
University
now during these days has a special sash
which you can wear for life it has a
very nice award as well
[Applause]
good morning my name is joanne liu and
this year drei Harris Tokyo who bets a
Karen Warner and I had the great honor
of serving as co-chairs of the 2017
class gift campaign today we are proud
to announce that 73% of our graduating
class contributed to this campaign the
class gift represents our class's
support and commitment to Columbia Law
School it is our way of giving back to
the place that we have called home for
the last three years saying thank you
and helping to improve the experiences
of future students
my fellow co-chairs and I would like to
thank our 50 amazing class gift
committee members and the 547 members of
the class of 2017 who helped make this
year's campaign a resounding success
good afternoon my name is Karen Burnett
it was an honor to represent the LLM
class of 2017 and be part of a community
that we formed as classmates the class
gift was a great way to show our
appreciation for the unforgettable year
that we lived here at Columbia Dean
Lester we are very excited to present to
you with a scroll of Honor yes
the scroll lists the names of the 278
JD's and 269 LLM students who
contributed to the 2017 class gift thank
you again and congratulations to the
class of 20 to 70 married your wife is a
litigation partner and senior chair at
Debevoise & Plimpton LLP where she
counsels board of directors and
represents clients on significant
high-profile matters including crisis
involving multifaceted government
investigations and cases miss white also
has a distinguished record of public
service having just completed a nearly
four-year term as chair of a United
States Security and Exchange Commission
and previously serving as the United
States Attorney for the Southern
District of New York the nation's
premier US Attorney office for almost
nine years
miss white graduated from William and
Mary high fever Kappa with a BA in
Psychology The New School for Social
Research with the MA and psychology and
Columbia Law School with a JD where she
was an officer of the law review it is
my great honor to introduce the class of
2017 keynote speaker Mary Jo white
so the big decision I always have to
make is do I get on the milk crate that
is standing by me so that you can see me
I'll try it without you let me know but
seriously thank you very much
Janice for that introduction and thank
you the class of 2017 for inviting me to
speak today congratulations on your
graduation and congratulations on having
reached I think the last speaker of your
graduation so you can applaud that right
okay you know who put me last anyway
right but seriously as a graduation
speaker you always try to convey a few
thoughts worthy of this important
milestone and really the exciting future
that each of you has before you if the
truth be told though most of us don't
remember who the speaker was at any of
our graduations or a single word they
spoke and I think former Governor Mario
Cuomo perhaps said it best when he
advised humility he said commencement
speakers should think of themselves as
the body at an old-fashioned Irish wake
he said it I didn't
they need to have they need you to have
the party but nobody expects you to say
very much so good advice and recognizing
the heat and that I stand between you
and the parties that will follow today I
will try at least to talk fast seriously
it is a tremendous honor to be asked to
return to the law school 43 years after
I graduated in 1974 and 18 years to the
day since I addressed the Columbia Law
School class of 1999 I will say that
much of what I have to say to you today
is not so different from my thinking in
1974 in 1999 although a lot has happened
to me and the world since 1974 in 1999
as for me I am in the 47th year of a
great marriage and the 43rd year of a
great legal career thank you I have a
wonderful son and daughter-in-law who
are also both graduates of this law
school and more importantly the parents
of our spectacular 18 month old
granddaughter she deserves the applause
I am also back for the sixth time
practicing law devil voice and plimpton
where I was a summer associate in 1973
as for the world it is a harder more
complex place in 2017 civil and human
rights have never been more at stake the
planets continued existence is in
jeopardy free and untainted elections in
the United States and other democracies
are under assault by self-interested
hacking nation-states and the threat
from global terrorism is even graver
than when I spent nearly a decade as
United States attorney fighting al Qaeda
and Osama bin Laden culminating in the
horrific attacks of September 11th so
it's pretty daunting stuff and lawyers
will be involved in and needed for
absolutely all of it but where do you as
new lawyers fit into the picture the
answer is just about every
we're to explain maybe the best place to
start is with the informal title of my
remarks do the right thing
you are needed and ready before you
groan don't worry I am not given to
moralistic sermons my message this
morning is more grounded in the reality
of the life you face is working lawyers
now that you are about to receive your
law degree hopefully about the passed
the bar exam and enter your first job as
lawyers most of you in the JD class at
large law firms where I also began and
spent about half of my legal career so
far when I urge you to do the right
thing I'm advocating primarily two
things first that you fully use your
Columbia legal education both as lawyers
and citizens doing so will include
working hard and embracing the
uncertainties you face today without a
script for what is likely to be 40 to 50
year legal career second in whatever job
you have uses your North Star your moral
compass that should always be flashing
to remind you to do the right thing as
you see it no matter what the pressures
may be to do otherwise your life as a
lawyer will not always be easy you will
not always win you will at times be
frustrated and even heartbroken that too
is part of being a lawyer you may have
heard the stories of these three young
lawyers one lost one of his first
criminal defense cases and saw his
client executed the second lost a large
civil judgment and nearly saw his client
forced into bankruptcy
the third young lawyer was himself tried
and convicted of treason the names of
these three young lawyers Abraham
Lincoln Mahatma Gandhi and Nelson
Mandela they were all obviously to go on
to greatness but the road was never easy
and they were tested again and again you
will be too but you have the tools and I
am confident the sense of purpose and
principle to meet every challenge there
were times as you sat in your classes
when you undoubtedly questioned whether
you'd made the right choice in going to
law school
and wondered what you were really
learning the work was hard the concepts
often elusive and difficult I remember
well to this day the terror we all felt
in my class of 1974 of being called on
and grilled by brilliant and some would
say a bit sadistic professors I think
there was only a couple of them left who
are still up here now so I if you see
someone coming from behind me please
tell me I remember too how inadequate we
felt when we compared our freedom
glimpses of insight to the dazzling
creativity deep knowledge and wisdom of
the exceptional scholars and lawyers who
have always been attracted to teach and
inspire at Columbia Law School certainly
in these ways and in the unsurpassed
quality of a Columbia legal education
the classes of 1974 1999 and 2017 are
much the same but the Law School in the
world in 2017 are also markedly
different two of the most important
differences are transformative changes
in technology and greater diversity both
in the law school and in the legal
profession my class of 1974 had only 45
women
and 31 minority students your class of
2017 as 196 women graduates that's 46%
compared to 17% in my class in 1974 it
is great and 34 percent of your class
identify as a member of a minority
ethnic group compared to 12% in 1974
students in both the JD and LLM programs
including all 700 plus of you
increasingly come from all over the
United States and nearly every country
in the world about 9% of your class
identify as non-resident a lens as
evidenced by your applause you know this
I mean greater diversity greatly
enriches your law school experience it
also dramatically enhances your ability
to communicate and resolve disputes in
the outside world which is itself rich
in diversity and in its spectrum of
difficult problems for understanding and
collaboration are essential whether you
realize it or not even now as you
graduate today you have been taught well
and you have absorbed what you need to
know to continue to learn and to grow
and function as a fine and high-minded
lawyer throughout your career you are
imbued with a respect for the rule of
law and fundamental fairness that will
never leave you and which must more than
ever be defended against those who would
ignore or dilute these pillars of our
justice system you've also been expertly
taught to analyze the facts of any
situation and to identify the range of
possibly applicable legal principles
that must constantly be drawn upon in
representing clients indeed your
professional career has been
jump-started by what the JD or LLM
degree you receive today represents the
Columbia law school diploma is uniquely
respected throughout the world and gives
you a presumption of excellence the rest
will be up to you do the right thing
by making your legal education and your
legal career count to make the
profession and the world a better place
you know while we're on the subject what
is this thing called the legal career
what kind of animal is this creature
called lawyer Roscoe pound one of the
towering figures of 20th century
American jurisprudence and being of the
Harvard Law School said this of the
legal profession many years ago the term
legal profession
is to a group of men thankfully now
women also pursuing a learned art as a
common calling in the spirit of a public
service in the spirit of a public
service no less a public service because
it may incidentally be a means of
livelihood so what does it mean to
pursue a legal career in the spirit of a
public service
what especially does it mean for lawyers
in private practice or private industry
at a simple definitional level it means
that all lawyer is a service business
and that all lawyers serve at least some
segments of the public whether it be a
fortune 500 CEO or an indigent defendant
but in the spirit of a public service
says much more by urging upon us as
lawyers the responsibility to also work
for the good of the public and for the
constant betterment of the legal
profession and society generally for
lawyers in the public sector the meaning
of pursuing their profession in the
spirit of a public service is pretty
clear working on behalf of the public
interest but what exactly does that mean
as an example a public prosecutor which
I was for about 15 years has the ethical
responsibilities of a minister of
justice and not simply that of an
advocate that means to always seek
justice to do what is right not merely
indict and convict people that broader
obligation is critical to the
credibility and fairness of the entire
system of justice although it is perhaps
not as obvious the private sector is
also a place where lawyers do and should
seek justice sometimes for a paying
client very often by doing significant
pro bono work and by always always being
a voice of justice within your law firm
and with your clients the legal
profession and lawyers are whether we
are the world like it or not involved in
nearly everything and every human drama
of any significance sometimes that means
a leading role in a monumental turning
point of our countries or the world's
history crafting then implementing the
Declaration of Independence
desegregating the South participating in
the Nuremberg war trials combating
racial profiling or police brutality or
stopping the environmental pollution and
warming that threatened us globally more
often
being a lawyer means functioning closer
to the ground preparing a will for dying
client drafting the deal documents to
finance a hospital or shopping mall
helping parents adopt an abandoned child
in a foreign country going to our
nation's airports to help immigrants
caught up in a travel van or helping
clients and I know a lot of you did that
through well thank you for that it can
also mean helping clients address the
legal consequences of a massive cyber
attack such as we saw last week really
around the world you can and each of you
will do great things and you will do
small but important things throughout
your career as for choosing a particular
job one size doesn't fit all and one
size doesn't or shouldn't fit anyone for
an entire career be open to new
opportunities and don't be afraid to
make changes in your career seize upon
grab as many slices of legal life as you
can that appeal to you spend time in
both the private and public sectors
don't let anyone else's view of what is
a good job or not dictate your choices
listen to yourself your heart as well as
your head and follow the internal voice
where and really wherever it leads you
that is the right thing to do with your
legal career now in whatever legal job
you have you will also be called upon to
advise your clients to do the right
thing sometimes you will be pressured to
do the opposite whether by a client
political or media criticism or because
it is the easier path I certainly
confronted such pressures a number of
times as US Attorney and chair of the
Securities and Exchange Commission when
editorial writers and politicians loudly
and quite stridently took a different
view of what I should do on a particular
case
or policy issue the pressure to go
against what you think is right also
occurs in the private sector albeit
usually less publicly when another
lawyer or your client tries to convince
you of something you do not believe is
right stick to your guns as in every
profession and in everyday living your
greatest asset will always always be
your integrity
never compromise that even once do not
deviate from what you know is right
even if it is for a good cause or might
help your career guard against using
your talent and considerable
intellectual and technical gifts to
rationalize a choice that is too close
to the ethical edge remember nothing
about a lawyer requires you to
compromise your personal integrity and
nothing nothing is ever worth it you
know I also hope that you will take a
broad view of what doing the right thing
is when you advise your clients in a
speech to the ABA that Archibald Cox the
former Solicitor General of the United
States and Watergate special prosecutor
made he expressed his concern that so
few lawyers and this is a while back
obviously of the 1980s and 1990s they
did not seem willing to give advice in
the spirit of a public service to say
what is often very hard to say which is
yes the law lets you do that but don't
do it it's a rotten thing to do you know
that advice really does capture the
essence of doing the right thing and we
need you the class of 2017
to give that kind of advice when you're
advising your clients to urge them to do
what is right and to follow a course
that comports with both the letter and
the spirit of the law doing the right
thing in your personal and non-legal
life is also very important remember
that you are first a person a child a
friend a sibling and eventually a wife
or husband and a parent and if you're
really lucky a grandparent you are also
a citizen you are all of these things
first and then you are a lawyer you know
we lawyer sometimes actually forget that
we have our own vocabulary and way of
looking at the world that tend to set us
apart and exclude others we often work
so hard that we don't make enough time
for anything or anyone else not for
causes we care about not for literature
and not for our families and friends you
know I guess it shouldn't be a surprise
then that lawyers are viewed negatively
with some frequency you know all those
lawyers jokes must be coming from
somewhere even those of us who are
lawyers cheer loudly during the classic
movie Jurassic Park when the nerdy
lawyer is the one eaten in the point of
John by the t-rex every time right that
lawyers name by the way was Donald
Gennaro of the firm of Cowen Swain and
Ross where they got that somewhat my
husband's firm by the way but someone
not even a mother could like you know
the one with the briefcase the glasses
the Bermuda shorts who abandons children
to save himself
so don't be like Donald Gennaro be a
good person and a good citizen it might
interest you to know that I by the way
went through all of the seven other plus
names your names you have not one single
Donald and that one single Gennaro in
your class applaud yourselves so you've
got a head start on that one but
seriously as a citizen there will be
many times in your lives when some
practice some law or event will strike
you as wrong unfair or bad for society
maybe it will be the lack of gun control
racial or religious discrimination
domestic violence the death penalty or
the atrocities in Syria whatever it is
and whenever you see in justices never
be too busy to try and change things it
is the right thing to do for every good
citizen and certainly no less for
citizens who happen to be lawyers indeed
our legal education has given us special
tools that will often make us
particularly effective citizens in many
situations use those tools often to be
good citizens as well as good and honest
lawyers before I finish I'd like to echo
what some of the other speakers have
said and I'll ask one fine
thing of you and that is that you all of
you find a few minutes later today to
let your parents know how grateful you
are for them and what they have done for
you and that you recognize and
appreciate that your law degree is their
achievement - they have literally given
you life and so much more now it is up
to you to do right by them and the
generations to come by doing the right
thing with your law degree career and
life
so Gretch congratulations to the class
of 2017 you did it now go do great and
good things you are needed and ready
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
good afternoon
yeah afternoon my name is in Konya
whereupon i am the dean of admissions
for the JD program it is my honor and
distinct pleasure to present to you
Columbia Law School class of 2017
Suzanne IBB katie aber gala at it's
Lorant Shia Shawn Asher Rashid Ahmed no
Sochi at tjuku Arisa Akashi
and there's the best I can you me Sarah
and Al cotton John Vincent Allen
Jonathan Allen Erin sue Alton Jeffrey
amico Jacob barber
Sarat a dodgy anushka as sorry Adam
Auckland Peck
Rebecca ausdom Josephine Bay Colleen
Buren Michelle by Cheyenne van RG
Sanergy Zachary Fannin Andres Barajas
Catherine Barrett
[Music]
Jennifer Pharaohs Emma Bennett
[Applause]
Danielle Miranda Kerr Benson
Katelyn Bergen Jeremy Berman
Jeremy Bueller
Tracy Federman Robert bishop
Cassie black Brandi blocker
[Applause]
Irene Bloomberg William Bohannon
William gamma ball Jeon Oh Roger bond
Jacques Alex James Bergen Steven Bradley
[Applause]
Julianne Brauer Thomas radar Claudia
broadsky Elizabeth Brody Aaron Brown
Maxwell Brown CSEC fruits are Matthew
Burke
Andrew Butler Justin Keller on Lotus
Canon Nicholas Kara Nicholas Carter
Alexander Caballito
Joanna Diane cases joseline fascitis
[Applause]
J securely Caroline keen sorello Erica
Shea Patrick
Chen Victoria Chen Lindsay Turner
[Music]
choose lifetime huh nutshell zulan Choi
[Applause]
Choi sure chinma catch aku nak achoo
kuma
OOP ching-chong Amanda
Maria trophy Zachary Cobb
Francesca grace kakuzu
Catriona Cohen David Collier Kendall
Collins
Rory deny Collins
Matthew Cooney Abigail quirks Cooper
Jessica Corey
Sabri a Cornish
Daniel Crandall Brianna coming Carolyn
karana Alex Michael Davis daniela decked
our pod Denson David Deutsch Kyle
diamonds
Michael dibattista Samuel Dillard
Ashley Dixon Matthew Doyle some variety
or Carlos Estevez
Arielle Francine Evan Edwards face on
Angie Fang Leo Fortman Anthony Ferris
Melyssa Ford or neck
Patrick Feeney Joel Feigenbaum
Harry L Felton Kristen Julie Ferguson
Alex
Finkelstein drew Fischbach Andrea Flores
hate on Fraser Christina Friedman
[Music]
Elise bunk Robert Gagne James Gandia
Sidney Galen Matthew Gibson Nathan
Gilbert hi Gil
Margaret and Gerard Brian jente Jeffrey
glass Ryan Glover Michael Godby Brian
Goldman Danielle Gordon chase Borland
[Applause]
Simon greenberg Hilary Greenwald Remy
Grossbard Kevin gross finger
daily Guerrero Varun camasta Nika brand
[Applause]
Orion Hakala jang-hee Han GU Jihan
Colleen berend
DeAndre
Aaron Harris Rebecca Lauren Harris the
head Abdul Hafeez Abigail grape Hathaway
[Applause]
blessing Havana
Ryan Hayward Zachary happenin
Christopher Helwig
Kevin hennequin TJ heron Kent Thomas
Hebel Jeffrey Hamilton Corey Haims
[Applause]
Courtney Elise Hodge
Emily Hogan mark Holloway Michelle honor
Julie sure
[Applause]
Sandra crater Rajah Hussein Justin Quinn
Princeton Heinz Nicole New Jersey Larry
Austin Jennings Qian Yin Jing Amanda
Johnson Brian Johnson to meet Joshi
Mandeep Cora chi gong
[Applause]
Kathleen Kang Sun woo Kang Maxwell n
Kathlyn Sagar call
Beatrice Kelly Daniel Kelly Marie kill
monde Alexandre Ji Young Kim
[Applause]
Andrew Kim Clara
Yee hee Hyun Kim Scott Heartsong Kim GU
Min Kim hyun-jung Kim
he us up Kim Joon Wan Kim Karen Kim
Rebecca
Najee Kim sung on Kim Stacey Kim
Janko Kinoshita Josef Klim Arielle clay
pack for a teacher Kohler Wally
Andrea Kozak Oxnard
Connie Lee Anne Wong
[Music]
Lorna lon Kelly Landers whoreson I
became Oh Lara
Joseph lawless chase lacks judgin lee
[Applause]
hyun joon lee geon Suckley Janice Lee
suji Lee
Stacy seeand min Lee Michael Blair Amy
Lee Berger Jolie Oh Grand Marquis
Levitan Jake Lewis Ashley will erase on
[Applause]
Alice Lee Michael licks ting
Andrew lily-white Kelvin Lin Daniel Lynn
[Applause]
Sam Lin Michael Andrew liniment
Alison Leah Cathy Leo height young Chui
Leo Joanne Leo Liang Cheng Leo the dong
leav Alison low Shiva lager Raja
Robert Longton shoe young Cynthia Lou
Paloma loose Chi Asha lion Andrew
McKenzie
[Applause]
Carla McGann Auriemma boobie John maker
Arif semana watch Amy now Elizabeth
Mardan Kathleen Marini David Markowitz
Davis Martin Q Gregory Martin Ryan
Martin Patterson Michael Marvin
Katherine Massey to order Matty Ock
Philip Alexander mayor corner McKinney
Ethan mark Mahon Chris Mendes David
Menon David Miller Juliette Miller
[Applause]
Kathleen Minton pnina Musa Lillian
Morgenstern
Raymond Moss Julia Marie Michael and a
Clary Oh
Shawn Nadel
[Applause]
Chirag Nadeau pile none of our two and
Runa ravage Girgis Nassif Scott Nelson
Jonathan knew mark-paul nollie Viktor of
Assad you candy or Femi
Megan okay
Anya Crosby Olson Hillary Iran all right
Eric
Arthur Ormsby Candace oh sorry
Lauren Shanice Packard jung-ho Peck
Tiffany pan Gwen Park Bella Susan so hey
part Andy's Paris
[Music]
crying pain
Elizabeth para check Thorvald Peterson
Ted tokati Christopher Mathis distrito
Edward Popovich Mary Prager
Naomi produce Zainab Qureshi power ROM
[Applause]
Vanessa racehorse welcome grow right
Robin hope Suparna should be ready
Erica rich Luke Riley
David Richards Edwards Aveda Isabelle's
Guevara Roberto Rivera Tracy risk Tyler
Robert Camila do Regas Elena Vegas
Rebecca Rodriguez
go in so we get Alan Harold Rosenberg
Michael Rosen gloom Henry Roth Nicholas
Rafi re Luthor Katherine ceiba Daniel
sack Abdullah Salam Randolph
Salas Salas Oliver saw Mara Sanders John
Sandoval membrane Oh Alexandra Santana
Morgan Sanders Matthews Toronto Hannah
Schecter
Graham Schumer Tara Schwartz
[Applause]
Justin seed or Melanie Cedric
Alexandre supplier eve chateau
Anjali Perrin Anita do da Cassini cacao
[Applause]
Julius Sherman
Madeline ship
Daniel signer
Brandon short go trough Lorraine sub
Rachel Elizabeth Siegel Hilary Smith
Nicole Smith kathryn smith adam Spalding
Riley steel
Daniela Ellis Steven Zoe Sternberg
Sophie Strom Nicolas Stringfellow Ryan
strong Jason Martin Sugarman he young
soo hook Elaine son how you son Natalie
sight
Jill Monica
Szczerbiak Deborah yeah
Debra tang han wang tang-see Mong Cheng
Elizabeth Taylor pain done George
peeps Kristen Terman Jeffrey pen Ethan
Thomas Briana Elizabeth Brienne Thompson
Angelica cylinder Alexander Hong Kong
Tron these trends Christine say me lon
Buddha wada
Austin boom
Rebecca Osceola Nathan Souter back
Michael
basher Josh Alverez Rachel Wagner
[Applause]
Tiana Walden Haley Wallace
Katherine Walsh David Wang Alice Wong
Phillip Bane Warren Michael what he knew
she won we canna
walk trot
Matthew Weiner Alec's wife Charles wife
David Weiss Malia wife Reichman please
Whitman Julian Williams
Nicholas will ahem
Martin Willner Jane Weissman Channing
wizard Jones Jamie wolf hmm mark Logan
right Tina shoe Roger Yang Jason ye
Wooten ye Fung Jo yang Jessica Joo Jung
you bow how Joe
QZ true friends and family I present to
you the juris doctorate class of 2017
ah
good afternoon my name is Silvia polo
and I am the Dean for graduate legal
studies and it is my real pleasure it is
my real pleasure to introduce a
candidate for the LLM Master of Laws
degree ready Stuart Paris Oboro
Heba
Akbar Ignacio Alfaro Namrata sambasiva
Rao Allah
[Applause]
Reiner organs
Anselmo Algar 7al Tino's
Stephanie areas Meru fo re Mallory moto
Aviv of nany Alyosha
- bod Sara Catalina neat nur Mei Ying
born Xavier Barrera Gaskin
Isabelle Ortiz monastery over bola Ana
Baxendale all belkin Constantine banish
Lisa Berger's Jose Elias Vermeer Baba
uh no Bernard Camilla
Escobar Varela a mangy investors n
[Applause]
Catrin billion Timothy bird Maria Jose
FINA Blanco Thomas Allen bland shall
Boca
[Applause]
Brian Bowman Louise Claire Brown dlpool
a Harrier but Gianna
Calado policy on Oh Nicholas Canas Karen
Vernors Victoria can you Karina Cardozo
de Oliveira Christian Carpentier Andrea
Castillo Guevara
Silvia Cavallari Fittipaldi Danielle
Ruthie Buendia sirisha Moon Unit
chan young shot charlie
[Applause]
suction shot already Sadat Sima Qian
yeo-eun Chen Karolina Gabriela Cipollini
Roman Santa chivalry
[Music]
Jacqueline Chewie Choi Christian Hosoi
Savannah choke Anansie dog Kiara salento
Pilar column s yes a Rancho cuadrado
Perez Rosetta Anita das killer made
bajos impressed Ezreal Gabrielle de
Xiang's I didn t Michael Donaldson Baba
Duncan Jeff do PO Rodrigo Doron de la
Vega
Anya's 10th root al-biruni Natalia
Pereira de andrade Maurice de rocha
Tomas Fernandez stick
doli oh ha Isabelle Theroux Philip
forsberg Oliver preachy Andrea dolly
Nucci Martinez de la Vega Lucho Gregory
gan-chan Gao Anna Maria Garces Escobar
believe Agostini debo meet Akash
Noemi Kidman Rafael
he'll never read Gita Shanker Alexey
Julie Gonzalo de la Vega's all the third
Lena Gonzalez Diego Gonzalez Altamirano
Giovanni grass le Cohan Grinspoon re
good young son
[Applause]
Nicole Kirtland Sofia gay raka cuida
Kanaka Gupta gupti Gupta Pia Pia Keitel
[Applause]
Timothy Hamilton David James Hammond go
Johan
[Applause]
yes son hung
Paola Maria hang Patricia Hartman Rouen
terrible Maria del Mar
Auraria Chamorro Adrian lamb whole
[Applause]
shinny ho
Benedick Nicola Sturgeon Natalie hookers
war route for SEMA SATA porn 1 quo
Sebastian uber one who say well fast
Eric Hong Monique Sarah Hurley
Marty Johannes Helmer goose' real Ito
Yukiko Yamato Ria's aboard
no Jack Ma Sofia Jaramillo Italian
mashita in sanik Amelia Sonali Kapoor
Eduardo Desmond couple Alan's a Pikachu
Bartman Kashyyyk Alexandra Julia Kennedy
bright Mariana keeper yoon-hee Kim your
bunk in Manabu Kinoshita Paul's limos
Ramya Krishnan rod puppet Ayana able LAN
Chi hang Victoria Catherine Lanyon
[Music]
Vera Lizardi Yong Yong Li Chen Chen Lee
su Yong Li Sue Ann Lee claimed Oh Li
gong-gong Kali ma Jian Li Li Zheng Lim
away Lord met Metsu Luciana Lee repair
odd Alberto doriga Maciel Neto arey Maya
Camila
oh hello Jo be Molly geography new
Maria amlia mom Bertie
[Applause]
Julio Manuel Martinez Reba Ravi Martina
Abigail ma be in tangelo top your
birthday
[Applause]
Lisa Maria McInerney Harrison Yau
Collett min Alessandra Mistura Gina
Mitchell masaha Sami Yukawa Misaki
Mitsuko XI yang moe Matthew more on a
cell mukham vltava Tanya Mukhtar
nicholas w mall chanel mother Satoru
Murata
misako more itani Hamad Mustafa known
among the new shinnok Jerry - LaDonna
Kerr elysee nazar Rio su Kanaka Eugenia
tano Javier Napoleon Abreu Macarena
Naranjo Rocio neuron mousse and a Leo
[Applause]
Hiroyuki neva she David nagging born
Kersey an only yiwen on me genja a me
demon yuki Nishikawa benyamin nutburger
you pee oppa
[Applause]
Jacob Ian Oh be soon yay Oh haga doble
Maria Clara Oliveira Ribeiro trancoso
Peter James
O'Laughlin Niccolo apology oh sorry
co-author seminarian at the NASA Nicolai
at a lot of ozuna's Apoorva foreign
Japan
James Perry Chicago Machado passionate
Oh
Sahil Paul
Eliana Vevey Capella's Robles
Eugene come Sebastian Perez Dominguez
chase us Antonio Perez palazuelo Mariano
Perot Nadia Sally
[Applause]
sanic pizza Ponza Jacqueline Oedipus
Naresh
Poonam Manuel portal a Arnaz Prasad
[Applause]
chillin chewy
Tomas euros Jimenez khalaby Prasad real
para Christopher Wagner Jasmine rain
mafia Sheila Nadira Reza
[Applause]
Kiara D Kiki Elliott Rodriguez Tino
Martinez hacer Roku Ariana Rosato Fabian
watering high ball one high Ruka
thousand Daniel Ryan
Mauricio Salgado
Christina Samara a manga nudism file
Michael Michael Sampson Arturo Sanchez
Javier some diesel
Ksenia todava DeLeon anime asset Zara
Eleanor Sadler Shippuden Varun Shankar
so janya Shankaran Aditya Sharma chin
chin mean no Bhutto she Ronnie Gabrielle
Eduardo Silva vignola
Pedro Silva Bert
simoom Alexandra Sinclair dr. enstein
real thing Sonny Nimisha Supriya
Shrinivas Ashley Shrivastava
Alexandra senescu the Venice pier nithya
Sunil M chart a suitable Sarah takahashi
[Music]
mark tangerine hi aunt Oh
Bruna Louisa Tanaka Lopez Barbara J ETA
Zuko des Nardo Posada Penha minty Ron
Nessen extra space joy kanasu Lee Martin
Thailand Clara young seaman quantum tip
Ratana Oh Jeong soo Chania sang Tosca
when Oh Manuel Ulrich Angela Maria Prado
Matias Valenzuela Louis goober van de
Ven Adriana Vargas Maura
Andres de la Serna Nicholasville
Fabiana Viera Bob OSA mortelli
Ameer Vitale Maria be so Agha not seen
back wine channel one see sarin Lisa
Washington more it Oliver vitamin assess
fight simone beck time for part for fun
witcha would but are appalled wada
charge
Cindy woo yeah
kwang-soo Jing onion yang Zhi Liang AJ
Gilman
[Applause]
Alma's uhane hand you hi minion mehek
the part I get done tenez gum bitch
[Applause]
Jang Jong Yoon long Jiang Zi Yu Cheng
Cheng Liang John's away
Sergei Zuko
Andrea Carlo this viler
people's Oh Sebastian Julia
ladies and gentlemen it is my honor to
present the Columbia Law School class of
alright alright hi guys you know it's
crazy for me to be up here right now to
mark what is four great many of us our
last day of school for the rest of our
life and I'm saying so listen I'm not
going to provide you guys any departing
words of inspiration I think the
previous speakers have all covered that
but what I would like to do is take this
final opportunity to thank each and
every one of you for the incredible
journey that we've shared over the last
three years thank you first and foremost
for the warmth and kindness that you've
shown me and to others and for the class
notes that you've you've given
unsolicited after risk class and for
hastily scrambling down the answer to
cold-call questions for facebook
messenger we both be horribly wrong but
it was a team effort and I appreciated
that thank you for the pep talks listen
I know we've all had our share of
challenges over the past few years but
there's always that person or group of
people who are there to calm us down and
tell us to keep our chin up because
things are going to be ok y'all
seriously deserve a medal for that thank
you for making me laugh the hardest I
have ever laughed in my life for the
unconditional love the smiles the crazy
nights out the life advice to shared
all-nighters before a final exam and the
study groups I would never actually
studied because we were just having too
much fun
thank you for forcing me to grow as a
person for giving me courage and pushing
me beyond my limits I cannot be more
proud or honored to call you all my
friends and colleagues you will all go
on to do incredible things in life I'm
sure and I will be there cheering you on
every step of the way you know I really
do mean it when I say I love you guys so
friends families honored guests if you
could please make your way to Ansel
Plaza after the faculty recessional in
the student recessional for the law
school reception and graduates after the
faculty recessional if you could please
make your way follow your class marshals
to the bleachers and from them Kent Hall
for the class picture and one last thing
see you last class of 2017 Congrats on
being done
[Applause]